to get up close and personal with one of
Nevada's most haunted places the
Goldfield Hotel
this area is where
everything just what wrong for me
I think you may remember last Halloween
we introduced you to some local Ghost
Hunters paranormal voyages they visited
some of the countries the spookiest
places they're based here in Nevada but
the Goldfield Hotel they say is unlike
any other in fact they couldn't even
finish their investigation last time
because Celia one of the investigators
there she became ill and she was even
scratched during their time inside but
they went back they have quite a story
to tell you can watch the full
investigation on their YouTube page
paranormal voyages it premieres tonight
for Halloween and you can also see the
story that we did with them on our
website they're talking about the Crown
and Anchor Pub very haunted of course
right here in Las Vegas the gold field
is is haunted I believe it's actually
still for sale and then if you go a
little bit further up to Tonopah oh
they've done the clown Motel the clown
Motel the mitz Paw you can be visited
the middle of the night by ladies of the
night they've got it all on their it's
spooky next